i'd like to show you something very
helpful
uh to help correct this forward posture
situation where you're it's not the
whole body going forward but your neck
is going past this midline right here
let me let me show you something
on this spine right here you can see
this right here
so
whether you're sitting at your desk all
day creating this postural problem or if
it came from an old injury which i'm
going to talk about your head is
anywhere between 12 and 15 to 17 pounds
it's like a bowling ball and it's
resting on this little spine
so every inch it goes forward it adds a
tremendous amount of tension in the back
part through here now we have this
connection between the back of your
skull called the occiput
and the first bone right here called the
atlas okay and there's these really
strong ligaments and tendons and you
have nerves back here you also have the
brain stem that is right in this
location and that is the location of the
parasympathetic
nervous system okay another name for the
parasympathetic nervous system is rest
in digest
so having a problem in this upper part
of the neck can create problems with
insomnia it can create problems with
dizziness okay or even pots which is a
condition where you're standing up and
you're getting dizzy and you have to lay
down you're not able to handle the
adaptation from lying down to standing a
lot of stiffness a lot of constant
tension in the upper neck okay now when
i was in practice i would always ask
people
have you ever had any compression
injuries to your head whether something
falling on your head or you falling from
some place landing on your head i
remember when i was five years old
swinging on a swing set and i slipped
off and i fell
about three foot right on
my head okay creating a compression
injury right through this area that was
the start of my neck problems and the
reason i eventually went to see a
chiropractor
you also have tailbone injuries okay so
where you're falling on your butt really
hard the force will travel all the way
up the spine and actually gets stuck
right here in the occiput okay
so if you had a history of a tailbone
injury okay
chances are you have a lot of tension
and stiffness in guarding in the top
part of your neck which will pull you
forward eventually then you have
whiplash whether you're driving a car
and get hit from behind
okay and your neck goes back this way
and forward which you end up creating
trauma on the front part of the neck
right here because it's going to over
stretch or a front end collision where
your head goes forward first and you're
creating micro trauma in the back part
or even from the side someone hits you
from the side and your head goes this
way so there's all sorts of traumatic
things that can happen to your neck that
tend to haunt you later in life or you
spend eight 10 12 hours behind a desk
behind your computer and your head just
naturally kind of gravitates forward
okay so the question is what can be done
for this next situation well there are
three things that i would recommend you
focus on
the first would be a very very simple
stretch okay
now if you think about what's happening
if the head goes forward
the muscles on the front part of your
neck
and the upper chest are pulling you
forward okay they're too tight compared
to the back muscles because we always
have this balance between the front part
of the muscles and the back part now
logically you would think if the neck is
going forward we just have to stretch it
backwards but that's not how these
muscles work
a better solution would be to stretch
the back part of the muscles through
here okay going down
this way because what's going to happen
when you stretch all these back muscles
all through here going
forward
what happens is you send a communication
to the front part of the muscles okay
and the communication is relaxed so
anytime you stretch a muscle
the opposing muscles will automatically
relax so we're sending relaxed signals
to the front part okay when you
stretch the back part so there is this
first stretch that i'm going to
recommend called the jefferson
curl okay now this jefferson curl
is usually done
kind of a gradual approach from very
very light without weights to adding
weights and a lot of athletes do this
gymnasts
weight lifters etc but what i'm going to
recommend is to do it without weights
with not standing in a platform but
basically what you're going to do is
you're going to curl your head
forward as much as possible and then
curl your mid-back forward and start to
touch your toes bending your lower back
so your upper body is completely going
forward and what this is going to do
it's going to stretch the entire
posterior or back part of your spine and
your neck
sending signals to the front part
allowing for all these muscles on the
front part to be really really loose so
when you come out of this jefferson curl
you're going to be able to stand up
taller and it's going to feel really
relaxing now of course over time when
you're more flexible you can start
adding weight and really stretch not
just your hamstrings but it's a great
exercise to add flexibility and strength
to your entire spine now the second
thing i'm going to recommend is cervical
traction okay you can actually purchase
a traction device
an expensive one online maybe 50 75
maybe a hundred dollars
that will give you so much relief to
your neck
and
help you with your posture so much
especially if you had a compression
injury or even a tailbone injury in the
past
and what you basically do is you hook up
this device to your head and you're
either laying on your back and you're
putting this elastic bungee cord type
thing
on the other side of the door handle as
you close the door and you can control
how much traction is on your neck you
can also do this on the top of your door
pulling your head upward this way
creating uh this
separation between your occiput and your
c1 through here realize that the
ligaments through here are super super
strong and you can actually put a lot of
pressure on your neck to create this
attractioning effect between the occiput
and in the first cervical
vertebra but the reason i did cervical
traction in practice for 30 years
because it gave people so much relief
not just with their neck but
improving their sleep okay because
you're stimulating the parasympathetic
nervous system remember rest and digest
you're going to allow this person to
finally get into this relaxed state and
a lot of people carry so much tension
right through in here now there is my
device that you can get that's not
necessarily
a traction device it's more for pressure
points that you can put in the back of
your neck and i have videos on it it's a
very very relaxing but if you've had a
compression injury or a tailbone injury
you need to get a cervical traction
device that can literally reverse the
injury over time and i'd recommend doing
this towards the end of the day maybe a
half hour before bed for about five
maybe ten minutes
and you're going to find that your whole
body not just your neck but your mid
back and then your lower back are going
to
get into this relaxed state and it's
going to really improve your sleep
because try to sleep if your neck has
constant tension you also notice the
range of motion the neck pain and maybe
even your headaches will go away as well
now the third thing i would recommend
after the stretching and the traction
would be neck strengthening exercises
and you would get on all fours and
you're going to start to do extension
type exercises as well as on your back
doing flexion type exercises and i did
put some links down below of how to do
this because a lot of times people go to
the gym and they're working their entire
body but they don't actually strengthen
the neck and if you're behind the
computer a lot you can actually lose
this normal curve that you should have
in the neck and you have to do things to
actively
undo
that
micro trauma now i'm really curious
about your past have you had
any trauma to your neck whether it's a
compression injury tailbone injury or
whiplash injury go ahead and comment
down below and then after that i think
you should watch this next video on
whiplash check it out i put it right
here
you